hi everyone welcome to my lecture about
middle games so today I'm going to show
two of my French games and I'm gonna
talk about the French middle game so
French is one of my all-time favorite
openings I've been playing it in my
whole life so I have some nice win some
really bad losses too so I wanna I'm
going to focus on the win over which is
this variation does anyone play the
French with block nice
does anyone face the French Andy for
play right so against the French where
you play I used to play the advance -
now I play 92 and actually have well I
have trouble facing 92 but I also have
trouble playing 92 so there's something
about this NIDA to move that really
bothers me but if I've French place -
lots of facie 5 but I think the really
good players who play 5 they do really
well with it like grease Chuck when he
plays the advanced French like his games
are amazing but again overall if you're
playing a French player you go 5 usual
they're just very happy yeah so white
has several ways of facing the French so
the reason I'm focusing on opening
because like we need to know something
about the opening to play the middle
game so this is something has to be done
about this e4 pawn so you push it you
take it or you defend it so there's a
big difference between 92 and 93 what is
the difference you're defending the pawn
so if your opponent takes there is no
difference because you take back but for
black how do the options change yeah
I'll ask both of you so you choose who
goes first right so when you play 92 in
some ways this is very nice because
again black has to make some kind of a
move let's say Knight f6 so you can
defend your pawn chain so 92 is a little
bit more flexible the problem is in the
long term does not only taste kind of
bad so you constantly have to find ways
to fix it so Knight c3 it doesn't have
this issue but a problem is after a move
like Knight f6 again now I'm going to
play c5 and I'm going to challenge
your Center so you don't have the option
of playing c3 but your Bishop is open
and not to say one is better than the
other it's a matter of taste but like
this are the differences so I play we
should be form
sorry 597 take take c5 so so I mean this
is one of my favorite positions to play
and so let's see what's going on in this
position the play we should before you
play Knight f4 I mean sorry Knight f6
against Knight bit 93 so you play the
win over so you play this position so
what can you tell me about this position
yeah so this is a structure is a chronic
weakness for white because even if I
exchange ok let's say you take out your
knight even if I exchange now you have
this weakness so this structure is
always going to be weak for white so it
generally end games are pretty good for
black because I can play with this
structure so what is the problem for
Bach yeah so the black the dark square
Bishop is missing so if black white can
somehow create weaknesses let's say if
you played g6 iron that just looks
terrible because this Bishop is just
going to come in so there are four moves
for white so a four Knight f3 h 4 and G
4 so we can go one by one
so Queen g4 is the most combative move
wait
that's why because right away you're
putting pressure you're attacking and
your opponent has to make a decision
EEMA I think I'm going to castle I'm
going to play Queen c7 and give up this
point and right away you're trying to
take advantage of the fact that you have
this bishop and if you look at the pawn
structure this Bishop is not that great
so White has to create
squares for this because if we look at
this pawn structure this Bishop is stock
so if we take out all the minor pieces
and we're left with night versus a
bishop then we're gonna have a classical
good night versus a bad Bishop some
let's say my net ends up one c4 and you
have this bishop and all the minors are
gone so a for the Bishop comes out on a
three that's the whole idea
so this is so queen g4 is an active move
a four is an active move H
or so this looks a little unusual
because so far white is just playing
with pawns so the idea of h4 is again
the same so I'm pushing h5 h6 so you
have to react to it this is actually
going to be my second game so I'll talk
about it more when I show that game and
Knight f3 which i think is the list
ambitious move white is just developing
cancelling which of course gives black
time to do something so Knight f3 which
was played Bishop d7 sorry we should um
so there are a lot of moves like and try
to Castle queenside this knight c6 Queen
a5 going after this pawns so be six so
usually I don't believe in this b6 move
because it's just a little bit too slow
but white is not really putting black
under pressure so now there's time
simply just want to trade the bishops as
it was pointing out this Bishop is just
horrible and this Bishop becomes
horrible starting from the first two
moves is sixty five so it gets stuck so
again some move like if your opponent
for example goes h4 you've got b6 h5 and
you're under pressure like you don't
really have time you need to play Queen
a 596 and put your opponent's Center
under pressure but since your opponent
is playing something night after you
have time so b6 so check so the point of
this check is what
right so you can either play Bishop e2
visual basic so you can throw in this
check your proof for walking Bishop d7
and then there is no trade so Bishop d3
and you should pay for so this is very
typical to put a piece on a4 first of
all that we're putting pressure on this
font second of all we are stopping this
bishop from getting out and as I pointed
out white really needs to create squares
for this bishop which is why queen g4 is
plate h4 is plate otherwise this Bishop
just gets stuck so a for Bishop beta is
of course a great diagonal another thing
that I have to mention playing c4 this
kind of a concession because black
really wants to keep the pressure in the
center and be able to either take on d4
or just keep the 4 under pressure so
white is usually happy to see this
because blacks counter plays on the
Queen side & Wine's plays on the King
side so when what causes the center with
a move like c4 that means what black
doesn't have any active place white can
just start playing on the King side
slowly but here we're doing it for a
very specific reason because we're
stopping this bishop and we're creating
this weakness so this this is a very
unusual setup so normally night goes on
c6 Queen gets out maybe castle but here
we'll play it a little different h6 of
course we're not going to let the pawn
get there now King the sound so what's
the idea of this move the taxpayer so
far eyes are safe so I'm going to go to
the Queen side so for y to do something
it's a little risky right to play like
g4 g5 okay you can open up your bishop
but your King is here and the Starks for
is nothing is really happening on it are
squares so what's a target in White's
position
well ce3 not really a target because you
can defend it and we're not really even
attacking it
what yeah
what's the target the blood can attack
so king D 7 so because Queen if I put a
queen on this 7 it's not really doing
much and because of the pawn structure
and the closed nature of the position
and black is not really going to get
made it because there's no way to get in
minor pieces are blocked the route
cannot really get in so we're not scared
of playing move like king b7 so what's
the reason of the pudding tonight on c7
instead of c6 right so if you go Knight
d5 you're attacking this pawn also in
the future if your opponent goes f4 f5
this pawn is defended so the knight on
c6 usually when black puts the knight on
c6 the pawn is on c5 so there's a pawn
here so the knight is attacking wants to
go to a 5 c4 but here doesn't make sense
so King the 7 coin goes here defense
defense so the position is very close so
if white doesn't do anything it's very
hard to break through so here I started
to get a little adventurous I think I
just really wanted to win this game so I
want a 5 which is a little double-edged
so I'm trying to open up the position a
little bit to create squares for my
pieces because like Bishop on a4 is
great and I don't b5 is great but then
the question is what's next and it's
hard to improve them and everything is
defended so if white just doesn't do
anything just shuffles around it's hard
to make progress but what's the downside
of playing a move like this right so my
king so I'm basically I'm playing where
my King is right now my king is in the
center I'm opening up the center royal
what else
and challenge what I would have 6n well
the reason I mean I could have just
played f6 as well but my idea is to play
g5 and my opponent probably has should
take this pawn because if you don't you
make some like any move then I'm going
to push you 5 and all of a sudden the
species are getting in this Knights
maybe not so great and then maybe f4 and
my king is still safe so what does my
opponent have that I owned and that's a
very broad question what's the piece
that I'll give up in the beginning
that's where bishops is a pair of
bishops so if we open up the position
who isn't going to favor white so black
has to be very careful so takes takes
Knight g4 so Queen g7 so some things
have changed so what's going on in the
position now
so this d4 Knight is actually very
annoying why exactly so this is a
knowing part if I play at five this
night is going to come to e5 and darts 4
is not only if I was just horrible
another thing is now all of a sudden
things like this can start to happen and
I have to worry about my dark squares so
you know very dynamic position so here
so where does black want his pieces so
for white I think it's obvious Bishop
will go on f4 rook will come to the
center the Queen is going to go like
here and here because now white also has
squares for his pieces so what is plug
can I do so now we need we have some
space for our pieces we can actually
move them so we're which the bishop
probably should stay there so now we
need to do something with our Knights
and then like what's your plan why do
you want your pieces if I give you a few
moves how would you rearrange them so 95
is what I played so my idea is a night
only f5 defense is pawn so my queen is
free to move around and this night is
going to go where these six only four so
perfect square for a night if white
takes and I'm very happy because III
this Bishop is going to become a monster
so Knight f5 after the computer likes 96
zero house we're looking at this
position with Yasser and he like 96 too
but I think night at five is fine so
Queen before so we have two options
either the bishop goes back or defend
the bishop so this is possible but looks
a little bit scary with the Queen coming
in maybe rule calms or some some kind of
sacrifice and and also this is a very
big commitment because now my bishop is
stuck so unless I can somehow play a
fight before this [ __ ] like I
understand it's a great Bishop it's
attacking its take keeping this rook out
of the game but it's committed to being
on a4 and I don't know if I want my
bishop there so Bishop c6 so when the
bishop moves now with option does white
have right a4 a5 and try to harass me on
the Queen side so Bishop goes there
first so night f7 so I want my night on
g5 attacking this Bishop so rook t1 is
against e5 so if I've it's a little bit
of a scary move but if I can get any
five without my position collapsing then
you know making progress
so here right here a four so again it
looks like white black has made a lot of
progress but unfortunately it's still
very hard to continue because it's not
on g4 is still very annoying so here I
realize my attack is not really going
anywhere so I thought time to switch to
an end game because if we exchange the
piece is this c3 pawn is under attack
maybe I can push like a6 b5 as I played
here okay three of course I have a
threat I want to take and play Knight c3
so rook to e8 so B so of course we're
not going to take so does everyone know
why white is playing here yeah because
again dark squares is because if you
don't do this I can just take play a six
and completely block the position so the
point of a six is so b5 is a target now
maybe I should be stuck defending it and
then in the future you want to play
Queen a5 and again play on the dark
squares so route g7 Queen a 5 so now
there's a threat so my opponent makes a
blunder so what to do well I mean that's
the threat because if rook takes b5
because what is the main defender of my
position this bishop right so if this
bishop is gone it's not clear what's
going to happen to this King so what I'm
saying blunder how you don't have a
check checkmate but what what's change
in the position I mean a lot has changed
in the position compared to let's say
where I move 32 let's say if we take
this position or even like this position
and then we go all the way
here so a lot has changed so what are
some of the changes in the position
remember it's very important to keep up
with the changes so it's important to
learn how to understand changes how to
summarize positions so the kink the
black ink has moved right how is that
significant the king was in the center
now it's on c8 I mean to me it looks
like it's closer to everything actually
because now the pieces are here well
okay but let's compare a lot has
happened so in this position if we're
looking back when my bishop was on a4
and everything was blocked so my pieces
are where so my peers are in the center
and the King side mainly white has moved
all his pieces to the Queen side so all
this look we made all this moves away
maneuvered with it you know improved our
pieces but now so much has changed so
white has moved all his obvious major
pieces to the Queen side to rugby five
allows all these attacking ideas as we
could creep on the dark squares Queens
on the dark square Bishop is on this
good diagonal but what has happened and
plugged in on the King side
yeah but yeah so but still the minor
pieces are here but when I was talking
about this night on g4 so what has
happened that night g4 is a target now
was my Queen on yourself
my Queen on g7 ever attacking the knight
no but now there's a rook on g7 so what
can we do right so now this net can
actually become a target because now we
can play rook g8 and we have this G file
we're attacking the knight so that's why
all these pieces have moved right the
Queen came here the row came here we're
trying to double but if you're going to
play the rook on G you have to calculate
some lines because your pawns hanging
and also your you have to consider how
big of a threat is rugby 5 so if you
think it's a big threat then maybe you
need to stop it today I played this so
my opponent starts for a while he didn't
take that scare although why is it like
this
so I think so this game was several
years ago I think I was calculating
night eg3 but black has a lot of options
here so now everything is forced so now
we can just calculate force lines so we
can use what we learned about how
calculating force lines to calculate
result so we also have to keep in mind
that 98 temple moves so we have to do
something very forcing so we have to do
something about this Bishop b5 I think
Knight f5 which is going to hang
everything yeah Bishop takes
really want to give away your work so
here we can take advantage of the fact
that this night h6 is always a target so
we can just take on g3 right away and
also when we take on g3 we were setting
up this discovery attack so when they
take on g8 so I calculated during the
game I think during the game this is
what I calculated
wait so 98 something something crazy but
my main point was if my opponent takes I
can just take and still the 5 is in the
air route g3 is coming but actually
Knight FG 3 is more accurate because if
here what move do I have and it takes it
to so so looking at this position and
like building up your intuition of
attack so why does something like this
work here right because right I have
everything going for I have an ID only
for Bishop is on the diagonal so all of
my pieces are on the King side so if I
don't have something now when all my
pieces are on the King side and a lot of
the whites pieces are on the Queen side
like when am I going to have a chance to
do something
and of course Ruby 8 is a temple move
and as I mentioned when did this night
come to you for for [ __ ] ah what move so
move 20 so for 12 moves we're struggling
against this night and now we finally
have a chance to get rid of this night
so we really want to look into it so
here let's say Knight h6 so take
so what's the next move so check so King
gets to attack so we have to take so
will last an exchange
right three five
and this King here not going to survive
for a real long so I have this great
night only for that cannot be kicked out
if the bishop moves I am I can simply
play something like Queen d7 and attack
you on the light squares or something
like Queen 87 it's like this pawn target
this pawn so we're done in exchange but
the blacks position is completely
crushing so what happened in the game
was very unfortunate so my opponent
played f3 so again I can take on g3 and
then he took and here I started seeing
ghosts so what to do with block this
here yeah yeah so here so here I don't
know if I miss this perpetual or if I
was scared after Queen III but here I
can just simply take because after take
take here working the King go King Juan
el kinga seven-night gcg it is a check
King c6 and amazingly just no checks on
the board so if you take I can start
taking everything's King runs and still
no checks well you can check but I can
block and you don't have checks or I can
run away so yeah I'm not sure if I miss
this or if I didn't see the perpetual
night that I'm winning anyways so I took
here and then the game ended in a drum
so looking back at this position so some
significant moments just to sum up so
this is opening knowledge so I noticed
this was a line but you know closed
position so we don't have to worry so
much about the king pink in the center
and here we save time because the Queen
on this zone as I mentioned is useless
so we have this nice maneuver so as I
mentioned this f5 move is a very
double-edged move because things can
easily go wrong and then my King is
stuck so because it's a middle game
I mean it's a closed position in the
middle game where maneuvering the knight
goes in a closed position you cannot
really maneuver your bishops they're not
really doing anything so this night on
g4 is I mentioned very annoying piece
the main dynamic is if F if f5 the night
will come to e5 so I cannot kick out
this night so my whole game is playing
against this and around it when you
bring my knife to cut squares I key for
and f5 so after we maneuver everything
around so this is another important
moment so our Bishop was good here it
did its job it attacked and it's a
little too scary to commit the bishop to
a4 permanently so it's okay to move the
bishop back because this attack with a4
a5 can be met with b5 and now this
Knights are very good at securing the
King so after all this maneuvers I've
reached this position and now that White
has really committed this major pieces
to the Queen side going here now we have
the opportunity to do something so once
we put our pieces on all their ideal
squares knives good time to look for
something tactical and something to do
okay so next game I wanted to show and I
really like playing the structures of so
many games and and sometimes it's very
easy to lose because if you don't find
counter play White's position can be
very nice okay say 46 so h4 so why can
white get away with a move like h4 so
we're move 7 and why it has no
development
so the center is closed and what else
when another major thing is it's a
question of this king because if you're
pushing h4 h5 h6 it's very scary to
castle so it's really asking this king
where it's going to go and yes the
center is closed even if we take on t4
the center is still going to be closed
because like something oops even if you
do something like this okay maybe I
don't want to trade Queens
maybe I'll queen g4 here you know we
cannot really do anything against my
king and black also it's not like like
it's so head and development that we
have to worry about it
so h4 I think is a very combative move
this h5 h6 idea is very scary and like a
real threat you cannot just ignore and
let the run home run there and then you
know kind of let this Bishop get in then
you're going to be in trouble which is
kind of what I did in this game so 96 so
Queen a5 so black has to look for this
active counter play and Queen a4 so
we've seen this idea before putting the
Queen here trying to block it on the
light square so this Bishop doesn't get
too active and here we have a specific
idea because we're putting pressure on
this d4 pawn of course if white ever
does something like this then we're more
than happy
so h6 take
so again a very double-edged position
and so what's going on in this position
well yes so there are a lot of this is a
very dynamic position so other than that
last position more maneuvering more you
know improvement here this is very
dynamic so in this kind of position it's
very important to you know you want to
be more precise and you want to play
active that's another dynamic position
if you're a little passive you're just
going to fall behind okay so what's
going like what's important in this
position what's going on whoever plays
French this should remind you of the
poison pawn so the poison pawn
it's this line so usually so you have to
do something about this point cannot go
g6 that's suicide so you can either
castle or play Queen c7 again very
dynamic position
you lost a pawn and I mean okay a little
different because where am I let me go
back so I can a little different because
H file is open I'm not down upon but
again the dynamics are kind of similar
so okay so what's going on in this
position there's a reason why white
wasted one two three four moves to do it
so you waste for most you've committed
four moves to open up your bishop so
it's very important for Y to activate
this bishop so a move like Bishop g5 is
something to be looked at so again very
dynamic position if you play a little
slowly then I can take on c3 put a bush
Bishop on d7 I can Castle queenside even
and then the question is going to be
where is this king going because if you
make he'll let white let Plex solidify
the position then your own king can be a
little you know
danger because if you if I take on g7u
Castle kingside and that's like an
invitation to the tag so with waste we
spend all these moves to do something on
a dark square so it makes sense for
black for white to continue doing it so
the way my opponent played I think she
kind of lost track of what she was doing
and generally they don't really have a
good grasp on the position and it's very
difficult because you know it's a very
strange position so again it's a dynamic
position so activity is very important
so white played something like Knight f3
and Bishop d3 which is okay developing
moves but not dynamic enough so the move
that we can't want to look at is Bishop
g5 simply because if you take now I have
this monster Bishop on f6 so I don't
care about the spawns as much because
now first of all your rook is under
attack but now my e5 pawn is protected
so this h7 pawn is always going to be a
target if you move your work I'm going
to take it and even if you take on c3
like I don't care as much because the
whole point is when white White has this
pawn structure when you have a pawn
chain what happens when you lose like
the root of the chain that are called
upon full so here if you lose this d4
pawn you still get to keep your ePHI
pawn which is the major pawn so this
Bishop is going to be very annoying so
it's going to be very hard for black to
deal with as for what yeah for black to
deal with that bishop so unlike the
other position now position is more open
so now the bishops can move and you
really want to look for activity and
just keeping the dynamic rather than you
know slowly I'm gonna move - like money
or my night from b5 like the mini R I
did in my last game like this Knight
maneuver so there's no time for this
because everything is hanging
everything's under attack there's a lot
of tension so here my opponent just
played Knight f3
I played Bishop d7 again she had the
chance to play here so I have to take
this so I cannot allow something like
this so this is game over
then rook is going to take or Bishop is
going to come and take and I just have
no moves
so I have to do something like take 57
and now this and the problem is now this
is going to hang now the night can come
in so a lot of problems for blog to deal
with so the Queen on a 4 in a way it's a
good piece because we stopped a 4 we're
putting pressure on a lot of fines but
at the same time it's a little out of
the game so in a more closed position
the Queen and a 4 is great so for
example if I place the 4 or this pawn
doesn't come all the way to h6 I'm
putting pressure here here so the Queen
is great but when the position becomes
more dynamic and oops there's a lot of
things are hanging the Queen out being
out of the game can be very problematic
so I played Bishop d7 so it's very
strange I have to say so everything like
so many things are under attack and both
sides are just developing like there's
nothing going on in the position so damn
so again it should be 5 as I mentioned
so she played Bishop d3 take ok so now
some things have changed so what
happened
a lot of changes in the position right
yeah oops
yeah not that I swear Bishop is on the
wrong diagonal now you don't want the
dark square bishop here within one the
dive square on this diagonal so the die
square has moved away
that's why bishop has moved away what
else what right yeah so the king is on
f1 and we have the G file open again
before we start looking for moves we
need to figure out what's going on in
the position the problem with Queen g4
is after a good g3 I'm going to trap
your queen this drops the Queen right
unless some holes later
okay it's a possibility but again no I
mean it's possible I'm not saying is
that but before we start looking for
moves
let's keep figuring out what's going on
a position with long term and short term
if I find a little bit weaker than
before since the pawn chain is gone so
where is this king gonna come Queen sign
right and what about this pawn it's
whatever
in which kind of position is white going
to be able to take because let's say if
I Castle so first of all you're not
going to take with the bishop and if you
take with the knight so problematic
right because you're inviting more
pieces
sorry 7-pound is weak but not easy to
take it so now that the bishop has moved
away what can we do again the position
is still very dynamic so the position is
also more open so we need to worry about
these bishops becoming very strong
because if this bishop somehow ends up
on d6 or f6 this King is not going to be
very happy and then this pawn is going
to be more of a problem so even in this
position is Bishop g5 available maybe
you should still consider playing this
so Bishop going on this diagonal is
already a big concession for white so 96
tonight f4 is a big threat so how to
capture back
well one of the most interesting thing
about the French is once you get your
bishop in the game is like you're
playing with an extra piece because the
whole game that Bishop doesn't exist and
all of a sudden the bishops in the game
is like an extra piece that your point
has to deal with so I mean okay I think
both moves are playable so what are the
reasons behind each move
what's the downside of taking with the
rook I mean your pawn structure is still
compromised what about F takes you six
well so taking with the F 1 actually
improves your pawn chain as you have to
connect the pawns yeah if you can it's
actually computer really prefers I've
takes you six but I took with the rope
comb again playing for the dynamics not
caring so much for material but F takes
G six also has its upside so if your
opponent lets you play G five okay just
passing the move so you're going to
restrict this bishop after you castle
your Bishop can after you castle this
Bishop can come into the game and you're
taking control of the dark squares
limiting this bishop so here I hit
probably has to play something like
Bishop d2 and bring the bishop around
again so I think both balls are playable
so I've took root G six on my opponent
take now castle and so what's going on
in this position
now so again very dynamic position so we
sacrifice a pawn so we're playing for
compensation so we have the G file this
bishop actually has a future now because
after the knight moves maybe I can put a
bishop on b5 maybe push even d4 put a
bishop on c6 so this King is no not very
comfortable here so we have a lot of
calendar play for the pond so you're
taking on f7 let's see to him so take
taking on if someone looks very
dangerous to me so you can play the rock
eight six or even put this rook here and
this looks way uncomfortable for white
yeah so I can check and my a no Queen g4
is coming so we're done we are done two
pawns not denying that but um we have a
lot of counter play for it this rock h1
check is very nice so she played Cooney
- okay so now we need to bring more
pieces into the game so I played Knight
c7 and I played it for a specific reason
so the second the knight moves the
knight is going to go to d4 so this is
the battle right between the student
Knights over this d4 square as soon as
one of them moves the other one's going
to go to d4 so ninety seven ninety four
and nine f5 so I mean this is a very
significant exchange so what the White
has to take actually what can try to
recruit the one with the Queen okay so
this exchange happened so what's going
on now now there was 96 check
so my opponent is she exactly so when
you have so opposite colored bishops we
know in the end game where it dries in
the middle game when you're attacking
they're very dangerous because if I'm
attacking on the light squares this
Bishop is very useless because you
cannot protect the light squares so we
wrote about my pawn structure
so yeah this pawns are compromised but
so when you're doing something like this
what are you aiming for more general
well in this position the Queen the King
so if you're going to compromise you're
if you're going to compromise your pawn
structure create long term weaknesses
you're looking for like dynamic play
activity so what I'm looking for
imbalances the specific words initiative
because again in the long term I don't
want to get stuck with puns like this I
don't want to lose this f7 pawn so black
has two threads in this position one of
them are obvious you should be 5 another
one
f4 right so actually white shouldn't
have taken this white should try like
Queen d2 or something but then Nigerian
is - you know today so this position is
already kind of it's easier to play for
block the list to say regardless of the
evaluation because you have all these
threads Bishop is coming out g3 maybe is
hanging does not only for is hanging
Queen King is much weaker so black so
white has something to do something but
this piece should be 5 moves or p1
so what are we doing at forum so cannot
take so quindi dream
so we take 25
yup c6
yeah we don't want to get made it so
clean up some so all the pieces look
perfect so now it's time to do some very
precise calculation otherwise seven
ranking soon because white is
threatening mate actually it's we cannot
really stop the mate so everything you
do has to be very forced so jitter looks
very counterintuitive to me just
shutting down the file okay but so Jeter
Kingi one Rock g7 the problem is you
like you're really that that you're
opening up your King so at least there's
there's going to be a perpetual you
might even lose so we have to calculate
something which I I mean I at least have
a perpetual yeah you're right
yes mainly is going to run away in the
dark squares now but this should be five
of course looks like a very natural
movement it's to be calculated okay so
let's calculate okay
Queen eight six King G 1 G takes f to
what happens after King f2 it's very
simple like to move checkmate so many
ways to checkmate
ah I mean you don't even have to be so
fancy so after Kings you want as our
Queen a6 King do you want take take you
and have like so rook g2 King get
through you and have rookie - and then
King runs away you can just check and
take the Queen so we don't even have to
do anything
very fancy so the main move is king h2
there you have a four swing
so let's their candidate moves so queen
eight so so far everything's forced the
Queen eight six King G 1 G takes f 2
only temple move King H 2 so what are
your temple moves so root G 2 is one
there's another one right so we have to
move we need to calculate like this is I
don't know how many ways you have made
into everything wins there is that one
following to slide now okay vaguely
so f1 night so your opponent has three
moves Queen takes row takes king h2 so
what happens after rook takes we need to
so we brought our queen in so let's say
rook F to the French bishop right so f1
night so if the rook takes so our queen
is on a different diagonals when other
Queen can join the game so we'll keep we
need to soak engage three gets made it
on g4 King h1 I mean I have so many ways
to mate so check on me this one take is
one I mean just everything so here if
King g4 engage three then Quincy tomb 24
mates if Queen after rook GT wins so
cannot take so what happens let's save
Queen takes
yeah I assumed mumbling so rook takes
Queen eight-six of King here then rock
check when g6 mate actually location to
meet and then if King h3 which was
played King h4 right so now we have made
in three so she resigned but of course
sweet Queen one
exactly this is why we need the Queen on
a6 to protect the sixth ring so just
comparing the two games so another
position like you need to understand
what the position requires so in this
kind of position where everything is
hanging don't really have the time for
this low maneuver like [ __ ] like
everything should it looked very natural
by developing her pieces and you know
put like putting the pieces where they
belong and that's going to go in after
you the bishops going to go on details
everything looks very natural but
because of the nature of the position
you know there are so many dynamics and
so many other things are important in
the position it just didn't work out for
example this Bishop needed to be on this
diagonal it was very important for white
to put it black on the immediate
pressure because otherwise the way she
played I really got away with what I did
right a lot of this pawn run all the way
to h6 and also very important to note
that you're wasting so many moves to do
this to compromise my King sight and my
pawn structure then you need to take
advantage of it because if you spend all
this time and then do nothing then why
didn't you develop earlier why did you
spend all this moves just to come and
take this pawn and then do nothing so in
this kind of position very important for
white to understand where the pieces
really need to be as opposed to what
looks more natural and really improve
this bishop because otherwise blacks
position just became so nice and it was
because white wasted all this moves
playing gauge 4-h five eight six so if
you're going to waste all this time then
you know you need to prove why you're
doing this and then the way white plate
it's like she did one thing and then she
switched over and it just generally go
together alright so this is what I have
for today for thank you for joining me